basketball hockey college and NFL
football it is a great time to be a
sports lover and what better place to
check out the games have some
mouth-watering food and choose all from
an oversized beer list then tailgate
social and joining us right now is
General Manager David Williams and
executive chef Marquita Ward welcome
YouTube thank you a tailgate social with
the name tailgate is in the the place
it's got to be good tell us a little bit
about tailgate social tailgate social I
mean we have it all whether you're
coming for the drinks the food we've got
delicious delectable mouth-watering
value friendly menu options
um the game we've got that game you're
looking for whether it's UFC fights we
show all of them whether it's the
college March Madness coming up we have
it whether it's the big game we all are
anticipating and excited for we've got
that I do recommend booking some
reservations with us it'll be feel like
being at the stadium at the game yes so
do that and then obviously on Monday
January 9th we have the big college
championship game going on TCU in
Georgia we've already got the calls
coming in Non-Stop for that so you want
to join us as well we'll show all the
games all the volume we'll make it
happen for you is there any way to still
make reservations for that one okay and
how do people do that a couple ways uh
if you're in the area stop by talk to
either myself David William Chef Kita
she'll be around as well
tugaysocialv.com as well you can book
that through the website itself
personally or online Open Table we've
got all kinds of options and avenues to
go down to get that reservation well
Chef let's talk about the other star
next to the sports the food and you have
brought us just some amazing looking
food here tell us what tailgate social
is known for food wise and what's the
must-have thing you gotta try I will say
our pizza we're really known for our
pizzas our burgers and our wings those
are our three top sellers and followed
by our Philly cheesesteak
um so we thought about the big game so I
wanted to come up with a platter to feel
like six to eight people so this is what
we have today we have our mini
cheeseburgers that you'll receive you
can either get that or the pulled pork
we'll have a two pounds of our wings you
can do your uh choice if you like of any
sauce that we have but we have our
traditional Buffalo you're going to also
get a pound of fries of your choice you
can do sweet potato truffle fries are a
house blend right here and then you also
have some chicken quesadillas and yes
everything is mouth watering you have to
try it no you said that's for how many
people six to eight I mean I I I think
three people I know would be able to
polish that off it looks fantastic and
then also the beers your selection is
crazy tell us a little bit about that we
like to go big not only over 30 TVs but
the beers as well anything from your
local crafts to your favorites uh your
your domestic your Imports we run the
whole game the whole Spectrum on that so
whether you're craving something light
something heavy your ipas your ciders
your Stouts we've got it all bring your
friends bring your family bring the
drinkers we've got you covered make your
reservations now like he said the
college championship game that is next
Monday right Monday the 9th 4 30. so
make sure you do those reservations and
the big game you know the one we're
talking about get your reservations for
that thank you guys so much thank you
thank you Jillian